ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY THIS IS
TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY NINTH. WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM IN FACT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MEMBERS HERE YET
SO I'M GONNA WAIT FOR A LITTLE
BIT. TO SEE IF WE CAN GET SOME
OTHER MEMBERS HERE BUT IF NOT WE
WILL START PRESENTLY AS A- SUB
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE CAN GET
MOVING ON OUR BILL SO. LITTLE
BIT OF PATIENCE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT EVENTHOUGH WE HAVE A
DISTINCT LACK OF MEMBERS HAD-
GOING TO START THIS IS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE CAN GET
THROUGH. ALL OF THE BILLS THAT
WE HAVE SO WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY. AND THANKS TO
THE AUTHORS FOR BEING HERE ON
TIME. SORRY ABOUT THE LACK OF
MEMBERS OKAY. YOU KNOW WE'RE
STILL ADJUSTING TO THE NEW NORM
ABOUT RUNNING BACK AND FORTH DO
YOU MIND IF I TAKE OFF MY- I DO
NOT MIND OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CHAIRMEN STONE AND-
MEMBERS. OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDED THROUGHOUT
THE ANALYSIS AND THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL WORK
ON THIS BILL. YOU KNOW IT'S A
SAD REALITY THAT SOME NURSING
HOMES UNITED STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA RETURN RETURN. RETURN
LINK TO ANYWAY. I CAN SERVE THIS
MORNING IT'S A GOOD ANTI
PSYCHOTIC DRUGS TO RESIDENTS
WITH DEMENTIA TO CONTROL THE
BEHAVIOR DESPITE RULES AGAINST
THE MISUSE OF SUCH DRUGS AS
CHEMICAL RESTRAINTS. THESE
CHEMICAL RESTRAINTS ARE BEING
PRESCRIBED TO SEDATE AND SUBDUE
RESIDENTS WHO OFTEN USE BEHAVIOR
TO- COMMUNICATE THEY'RE PAYING
THEIR DISCOMFORT OR DISTRESS AB
EIGHTEEN OH NINE WILL HELP STEM
THIS PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN REPORT BY THE HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH THIS ABUSIVE
PRACTICE HAS BECOME MORE
WIDESPREAD. BASED ON THE
RESEARCHERS VISITS TO MORE THAN
A HUNDRED NURSING FACILITIES IN
SIX STATES OR MORE. AND MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED INTERVIEWS
WITH PEOPLE LIVING FACILITIES
THE FAMILY STAFF LONG TERM CARE
AND DISABILITY EXPERTS
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND
ADVOCATES. HUMAN RIGHTS RIGHTS
WATCH REPORT THEY WANT DOCILE
HOW NURSING HOMES IN THE UNITED
STATES OVER MEDICATE PEOPLE WITH
DEMENTIA ESTIMATES THAT EVERY
WEEK THE UNITED STATES NURSING
FACILITIES MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
MOSTLY THOSE SHOULDER THE OLDER
AND LIVING WITH DEMENTIA ARE
GIVEN ANTI PSYCHOTIC DRUGS WITH
OUT A APPROPRIATE DIAGNOSIS AT
A PSYCHOTIC DRUGS WERE DEVELOPED
TO TREAT PSYCHIATRIC. CONDITIONS
LIKE SCHIZOPHRENIA. THE AND DRUG
. REQUIRES MY FACTORS LABEL THEM
WITH THE STRONGEST BLACK BOX
WARNING WITHOUT THE RISK WITH
ABOUT THE RISKS THAT THEY POSE
TO PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA. THE FDA
HAS NEVER APPROVED ANTI SOUGHT
PSYCHOTIC DRUGS AS SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE FOR THE TREATMENT OF
THE VICTIM DEMENTIA SYMPTOMS.
STUDIES FINEST ANTI PSYCHOTIC
DRUGS NEARLY DOUBLE THE RISK OF
DEATH IN OLDER PEOPLE WITH
DEMENTIA WHEN THE DRUGS ARE
ADMINISTERED WITHOUT INFORMED
CONSENT. INS AND THE FARMERS ARE
NOT MAKING THE CHOICE TO TAKE
SUCH A RISK. AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE
A BUILDS ON EXISTING PROTECTIONS
FOR NURSING HOME RESIDENTS IN
STATE LAW AND REGULATED. IT WE
WILL CUT IT'LL CUT A FINE EXPAND
RULES TO ESTABLISH A NURSING
HOMES RESIDENTS RIGHT TO PROVIDE
OR WITHHOLD WRITTEN INFORMED
CONSENT. PERTAINING TO THE USE
OF SPENT A THERAPEUTIC DRUGS AND
THE RIGHT TO BE FREE FROM
CHEMICAL RESTRAINT. WILL SPECIFY
THAT RESIDENTS AND
REPRESENTATIVES MUST BE INFORMED
IN WRITING ABOUT THE CUT CONTENT
WITH THE BLACK BOX WARNINGS FOR
PROPOSED DRUGS AND WHETHER THE
PER DRUGS PROPOSED USE. HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE FDA FDA.
REQUIRES THE STATE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH TO EVALUATE
NURSING FACILITY COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE PROVISIONS DURING PERIODIC
STATE LICENSE INSPECTIONS. I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT MY TWO WITNESSES
ATTORNEY CHECK UNTIL THE STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE BILL'S SPONSOR
THE CALIFORNIA'S FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM AND BE A REMOTE
TESTIMONY IS MATT BOREDOM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING I'M TONY CHECK
ITSELF FROM CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM. AS ONE
TALK TO YOU REAL QUICKLY ABOUT
TWO THINGS ONE THAT THE TIME HAS
COME FOR THIS BILL. A SIMILAR TO
A BILL THAT WE SPONSORED AND
THOUSAND NINE SB THREE OH THREE
WHICH WOULD HAVE BROUGHT WOULD
OF- CODIFIED PRE EXISTING STATE
REGULATIONS ON INFORMED CONSENT.
AND ENHANCE THEM- THE WE GET THE
BILL THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE BUT
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER VETOED
IT AND IN HIS VETO MESSAGE.
BASICALLY SAID I'M NOT CONVINCED
THAT THERE'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM
HERE LET'S LOOK AT IT. OF A
COUPLE YEARS LATER THIS ISSUE
ERUPTED NATIONALLY THERE WAS AN
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT THERE WAS- SENATE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND THEN
THIS. BIG NATIONAL CAMPAIGN THAT
WAS ADOPTED IN CALIFORNIA TO GET
PROVIDERS TO VOLUNTARILY REDUCE
THEIR USE. OF PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS
IN NURSING HOMES. AND FOR THE
MOST PART THERE WAS SOME SUCCESS
WE THE RATES WENT DOWN A YEAR
AFTER YEAR GRADUALLY. TILL ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OR
SEVENTEEN AND THEN THE MOMENTUM
OF THE CAMPAIGN REALLY. STARTED
TO EXHAUST ITSELF AND THE RATES
FLATTENED AND SINCE THEN THEY'VE
COME BACK UP ESPECIALLY. DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND IT'S BEEN-
PRETTY DISPIRITING TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU. SO THE TIME HAS COME-
TO DO WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE AND HAVE A
WRITTEN INFORMED CONSENT LAW.
THE SECOND CONCEPT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT JUST VERY BRIEFLY IS
THAT INFORMED CONSENT FOR THE
MOST PART IN NURSING HOMES HAS
BEEN A SHAM. PROCESS RESIDENTS
IF THEY GET ANY INFORMATION AT
ALL ABOUT THESE DRUGS IT USUALLY
JUST. BITS AND PIECES OF
INFORMATION IT'S NOT A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE CONVERSATION
THEY'RE HAVING WITH THEIR
PRESCRIBER. I'VE BEEN GOING INTO
NURSING HOMES AND ADVOCATING FOR
RESIDENTS FOR NINETEEN YEARS
NOW. I'VE BEEN I'VE SPENT A FAIR
AMOUNT OF TIME AND FACILITIES
TALKING TO RESIDENTS. IN THEIR
ROMS AND I HAVE YET. TO EVER
SEE A PRESCRIBER IN THE ROOM
WITH THE RESIDENT. AT THE TIME
E. VALUE WAITING THE CONDITION
OF THEIR PATIENT. SO THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF INFORMATION THAT
RESIDENTS ARE GETTING- THAT I'M
NOT REALLY THIS BILL IS NOT
REALLY FOCUSED THE CONVERSATION
THE PRESCRIBER SHOULD BE HAVING
WITH THEIR PATIENTS ABOUT THE
INFORMATION. THAT THE PATIENT
SHOULD BE GIVEN AND IT VERIFY IT
MAKES A VERIFIABLE THAT THE
RESIDENTS WERE GIVEN THIS
INFORMATION. AND- AND HAD A I
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT
BEFORE DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WERE GONNA TAKE THIS. THIS
DRUG SO OF VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU AND THEN WE HAVE
MATT BURDEN ON THE- TELEPHONE
OPERATOR IS NOT BOARD WITH US.
I'M I'M ON AND GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY- MY NAME
IS NOT FOUR NINE AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY AND I OF THE LAW FIRM
WITH OFFICES IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND NEW YORK. THE REASON THAT
I'M HERE THAT I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND HOW PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS
OF MISUSE THE NURSING HOME.
THERE IS NOT INTENDED TO
SUBSTITUTE THESE DRUGS FOR STAFF
THE IDEA IS THAT YOU MAKE THE
POPULATIONONE DOC FILE. YOU
DON'T NEED THAT MANY PEOPLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM YOU MAKE MORE
MONEY AND AT THE SAME TIME YOU
SHOT THE COST OF THE PRODUCT ON
BECAUSE THE TAXPAYERS BECAUSE
THE BALL PAID. FOR BY MEDICARE-
THE DRUGS HAVE A DOES. EFFECT
YOU BASICALLY. TAKE UPON. THAT
DIFFICULTY ARE. IT NEEDS OF THE
FIRST PLACE. CAN YOU MAKE IT
EVEN HARDER FOR THEM AND YOU EE
PEOPLE DYING OF DEHYDRATION. AND
YOU ALSO SEE PEOPLE DYING OF A
BROKEN HEART THESE DRUGS. REALLY
TAP YOUR WILL TO LIVE AND SO
THAT BLACK BOX WARNING WORDS THE
THAT IT DOUBLES YOUR MORTALITY
RATE. THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
KOPPEL REASONS THAT GO INTO IT
AND EVEN IF IT DOESN'T KILL YOU
KNOW I THESE DRUGS HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL AFFECT. YEAH I TELL
YOU HOW MANY. I'VE TALKED TO
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE EDUCATED.
WHO ARE CARRYING AND WELL
MEANING PEOPLE WHO THINK OF
THESEDRUGS AT THE Q. AND I
THINK THAT THESE DRUGS ARE GOING
TO MAKE THEIR LOVED ONES. THAT
ARE. I THINK THAT THEY'RE
TREATING THE DEMENTIA OR HELPING
THEM ORGANIZE THEIR THOUGHTS.
TWENTY ONE JUST THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE. THESE DRUGS ARE THE SAME
DRUGS THAT ARE USED IN- MENTAL
INSTITUTION BECAUSE OF THE MOST
VIOLENT AND DERANGED OF BANKERS
AND STATE- AND THEY CRUSH THE
HUMAN SPIRIT. AND I THINK THE-
OR ONE KEY TO. THE STATE MOST
VULNERABLE PART AND FOR. PEOPLE
NEED TO UNDER WHY THEY'RE
GETTING THEY NEED TO KNOW THE
DRUGS ARE NOT A TREATMENT FOR
DEMENTIA THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THE BLACK BOX WARNING. THEY NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF DOWNSIDE COULD BE
DRUGS AND THERE'S A VERY LITTLE
UPSIDE AND AN INFORMED CONSENT
IS THE KEY AND NOT HOW WOULD YOU
KNOW COULD BEGIN STOPPING AND IF
YOU COULD PICK UP THINK THAT.
THE NURSING HOME AND TO PROTECT. OUR MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS.
I THANK YOU. SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI EIGHTEEN OH NINE. RIGHT
AND I THINK- ONE OF THINGS I
NEGLECTED TO DO WAS TALK ABOUT.
WITNESSES HERE BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING. BACK TO WITNESSES HERE
IN PERSON BUT ALSO WITNESSES ARE
AVAILABLE ON THE TELEPHONE- JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
WHO IS WATCHING HAS THE NUMBER
THE NUMBER SHOULD BE UP ON THE
SCREEN. IT IS 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN RIGHT TO
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN OH NINE. CERTAINLY AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF SO I'LL
ASK YOU TO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S. ONE
ZERO.
GIVE US JUST A MOMENT HERE AYE
AYE AND ANY OTHERS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT.
AND IN A MOMENT HERE WE CAN OPEN. ONLINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
OH NINE THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME NINE FURTHER. I'M SORRY SAY
THAT AGAIN THAT THERE ARE NO
FURTHER. THERE AREN'T THERE
AREN'T ANY OTHERS AT THIS GREAT
THANK YOU. OKAY WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHTEEN OH NINE. PLEASE OKAY
YEAH.
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE STILL WITH
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION- ALTHOUGH I VERY MUCH
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS WE'VE HAD SOME REALLY
GOOD DISCUSSIONS- AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS- SITUATION WHERE WE
CAN'T COMPROMISE ON THIS BILL
AND I THINK- ARE CONCERNED- BOTH
ASSOCIATIONS CONCERNS I THINK
CHRIS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A BALANCE BETWEEN- WHAT THE-
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR. NEED AND
WANT WITH RESPECT TO MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A STRONGER
INFORMED CONSENT PROCESS IN
PLACE WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT-
I THINK WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROCESS IS THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE- DON'T DETER OUR
PRESCRIBERS ARE PHYSICIANS THAT
WORK WITH OUR PATIENTS- DON'T TO
TURN THEM FROM WANTING TO USE
THAT PROCESS AND MAKING SURE
THAT OUR PATIENTS ALSO HAVE
ACCESS TO PSYCHOTROPIC ANTI
PSYCHOTIC MEDICATIONS NGUYEN ON
HOPEFULLY MANY RARE OCCASIONS
THAT THEY NEED THEM AND SO- THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'RE HAVING-
REALLY REVOLVE AROUND KIND OF
THREE DIFFERENT POINTS. ONE
MAKING SURE THAT THE INFORMED
CONSENT OF PRIDE OF BRITAIN
INFORMED CONSENT IS OF IS A FORM
SOMETHING THAT BOTH THE FACILITY
AND THAT AND THE PRESCRIBER CAN
BE COMPLIANT WITH THAT WE'RE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE AND THERE'S NOT A GREAT
AREA WITH RESPECT TO WHAT THAT
IS I'M BECAUSE IF YOU COUPLE
THAT WITH BOTH I'M WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS IT PUTS IN PLACE. MORE
CIVIL LIABILITIES AND CITATIONS
WITH RESPECT TO THIS- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT BOTH- OUR
PRESCRIBERS AND OUR FACILITIES
CAN BE CLEARLY COMPLIANT- IF
THEY WANT TO BE- AND SO LAST I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT AND THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME REALLY GOOD
INITIATIVES AND AT BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND THERE WAS A- A
FAIR AMOUNT OF A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
REDUCED AS THE USE OF ANTI
PSYCHOTICS IN NURSING FACILITIES
AND SINCE THAT TIME THERE HAS
BEEN A 50% REDUCTION IN THE USE
OF AN ASSET HI. ANDERSON HOME-
WE DON'T DENY THAT WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
DOWNTURN IN THAT- AND WE OF LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO. ADDRESS
THE SITUATION- BUT WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS ABOUT ANOTHER
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH RELATED
TO EDUCATION AND TRAINING- AND
KIND OF COMING OUT THIS IN BOTH.
NOT JUST A PUNITIVE APPROACH BUT
ALSO IN A VERY POSITIVE
APPROACH- AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING MORE THOSEDISCUSSIONS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU DO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S. ONE ZERO.
GIVING A MOMENTARY YOU HAVE
NOBODY IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE THE LINES THEN AND I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
WAS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
THINK WE'VE- WE'VE SEEN TOO
OFTEN OVER THE YEARS. WITH
VULNERABLE. INDIVIDUALS ACTUALLY
ARE ARE OLDER ADULTS AND OUR
KIDS THAT. RESTRAINTS BE THEY
PHYSICAL OR CHEMICAL ARE OFTEN
USED WHEN THE- REALLY FOR THAT
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE FACILITY
THAT IT'S AN EASY WAY TO SUBDUE
SOMEONE WITHOUT HAVING TO LOOK
AT UNDERLYING ISSUES SO I TAKE
THE POINT FROM THERE THE
OPERATORS THAT THEY WANT TO BE
CLEAR AND I HOPE THAT THAT THAT
SOMETHING CAN BE WORKED OUT SO
THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR. WHEN IT'S
BEING USED OR NOT BEING USED BUT
I THINK WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
GET AWAY FROM. THIS NOTION OF%
INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS SORT OF
NATURAL FOR THEM TO DO TO WANT
TO PROTECT THE INSTITUTION TO
LOOK MORE BROADLY AT HAVE THE
ISSUES FUNCTIONS. AS OPPOSED TO
LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF
THE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR CARE
AND THAT SEEMS TO PLEASE IN THE
WORK THAT I'VE DONE IN THE
JUVENILE SPACE SPECIALLY. THAT'S
WHAT'S LED TO OVER PRESCRIPTIONS
OVER UTILIZATION OF. OF
RESTRAINTS TODAY GREETED IT IS
HIGH TIME THAT WE RAISE THAT
AWARENESS. AND IF THERE ARE
COLLABORATIVE WAYS TO DO IT
BETTER OKAY FINE BITES THAT'S
NOT HOW A LOT OF PLACES RESPOND
IN A LOT OF INSTITUTIONS ARE. ON
THE UP AND UP AND OTHERS ARE
JUST. IN THE BUSINESS OF TRYING
TO KEEP THINGS AS CALM AS
POSSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN INTERESTS
AND THAT'S NOT IN THE INTEREST
OF THOSE IN THEIR CARE. SO I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL. OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE. ALL RIGHT-
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY MAY CLOSE YEAH
I JUST WANT TO COMMENT IS THAT
WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION WE'VE I DON'T
THINK WE'LL HAVE ANY PROBLEM
GETTING TO A GOOD LANDING PLACE
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THEY DO MEAN A LOT TO
ME THEY MEAN A LOT TO THE PEOPLE
AND I CONSTITUENTS TO BE
REPRESENTED A SO AGAIN I JUST
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU IN IN. WE WILL DO SO
WHAT WAS WE GET A QUORUM WILL BE
ABLE AS A CHRISTIAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SHERMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. RIGHT LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN IST BLOW.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SIGNED. PLEASE TO PRESENT THIS
MORNING AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN
WHICH REQUIRES THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH A WATER LAW
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAM
FOR JUDGES AND WILL ALSO ALLOW
THE CHIEF JUSTICE TO ASSIGN
COMPLEX WATER CASES TO TRAIN
JUDGES. IT ALSO WOULD PROVIDE
JUDGES WITH EXPERT RESOURCES
DEVELOPED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO ASSESS TRIAL JUDGES
IN THE JUDICATA IN THESE COMPLEX
CASES. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND OF COURSE THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT WORK ON THE BILL. AS
CALIFORNIA SUFFERS YET ANOTHER
RECORD BREAKING DROUGHT
CONFLICTS OVER WATER NATURALLY
ARE ON THE INCREASE. THE
LITIGATION RESULTING FROM THESE
CONFLICTS AS FREQUENTLY OF A
COMPLEX NATURE REQUIRING
EXPERTISE AND SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO RESOLVE. THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS LONG
DEFINED WATER ADJUDICATION AS
PRESUMABLY COMPLEX REQUIRING
MORE JUDICIAL ATTENTION AND
RESOURCES. THE CHIEF JUSTICE MAY
ASSIGN SUCH COMPLEX CASES TO THE
JUDGES WHO SERVE AND COMPLEX
COURT PROGRAMS IN URBAN
COUNTIES. BUT IN SOME CASES
TRIAL JUDGES HAVE HIRED
EXPERIENCED WATER LAWYERS TO
HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEX
NATURE OF WATER LAW AND WORK
THROUGH OFTEN VOLUMINOUS
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORDS SOMETIMES
NUMBERING IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PAGES. THESE MAY
ALSO AGREED TO PAY A SPECIAL
MASTER TO INVESTIGATE TECHNICAL
AND LEGAL ISSUES FOR THE JUDGE.
HOWEVER THOSE OCCASIONAL EFFORTS
DEPENDED ON A JUDGE FINDING AN
EXPERIENCE WATER EXPERT WHO
DIDN'T HAVE CONFLICTS. AND THEIR
COURT ALSO FINDING THE MONEY TO
HIRE THOSE INDIVIDUALS. URBAN
AND RURAL TRIAL JUDGES WITH
COMPLEX WATER CASES WHO USUALLY
HAVE LIMITED EXPERIENCE IN WATER
LAW NEED GREATER STATEWIDE
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES TO RESOLVE
WATER CONFLICTS EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. WATER CONFLICTS
OFTEN AFFECT MORE THAN JUST THE
TWO PARTIES IN LITIGATION THESE
CONFLICTS CAN IMPACT AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES WATER OR CRITICAL
STATE WIDE NATURAL SOURCES LIKE
THE SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA. AND MAY EVEN RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER. AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN OFFERS A
DYNAMIC APPROACH TO DELIVER THE
CRITICALLY NEEDED TRAINING AND
RESOUCES TO ASSIST JUDGES
ACROSS THE STATE AND RESOLVING
THESE CONFLICTS EFFECTIVELY.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
CREATE A WATER LAW EDUCATION
PROGRAM FOR JUDGES AT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND SEEK TO
INCLUDE IN THE PROGRAM JUDGES
REPRESENTING COUNTIES WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF EACH OF THE NINE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARDS IN EACH APPELLATE.
DISTRICT IT WILL ALLOW THE CHIEF
JUSTICE TO ASSIGN CASES RELATING
TO WATER. TO A JUDGE WITH WATER
LAW TRAINING OR EDUCATION AND
REQUIRE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
IDENTIFY EXPERTS IN WATER
SCIENCE OR WATER MANAGEMENT OR
RESEARCH ATTORNEYS WHO WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANY JUDGE ACUITY
EDUCATING A WATER DISPUTE. IT
WILL AUTHORIZE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO PAY OR REIMBURSE COURTS FOR
THE COSTS OF EMPLOYING OR
CONTRACTING WITH EXPERTS IT IN
WATER SCIENCE OUR WATER
MANAGEMENT OR RESEARCH OR
RESEARCH ATTORNEYS IN AN ACTION
RELATED TO WATER WITH FUNDS
APPROPRIATED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
AND FINALLY IT WILL EXPAND
CURRENT LAW ALLOWING A JUDGE TO
APPOINT A QUALIFIED SPECIAL
MASTER TO APPLY TO A WIDER RANGE
OF WATER CASES. I AM PLEASED TO
BE JOINED BY RYAN BIZARRO A
SHAREHOLDER IN THE LAW FIRM
MARKOWITZ CHRONIC AND SHANAHAN
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. MR BIZARRE
HAS PRACTICED WATER LAW IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEAR AND WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER BLUE
SERVE FIRST WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING- AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM- INDICATED BY NAMES RAIMES
ZERO I'M A SHAREHOLDER BERKOWITZ
CHRONIC AND SHANAHAN R. WE HAVE
CLIENTS WHO ARE WATER USERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. PRIMARILY
PUBLIC AGENCIES WE REPRESENT
ABOUT 75% OF OUR CLIENTS
REPUBLIC AGENCIES IN VARIOUS
AREAS SO. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
WATER RIGHTS ATTORNEY FOR THE-
CITIES OF SANTA CRUZ- FOLSOM
AND- ROSEVILLE AND HAVE.
DISSIPATED IN AND LITIGATED A
NUMBER OF THESE- VERY LARGE
MATTERS AND SO WHAT YOU SEE-
RELATIVE TO THE NORMAL RUN OF
SUPERIOR COURT CASES IS THERE'S
ABOUT THREE REAL CROSSCUTTING
TENSIONS AND WATER CASES. THAT
OFTEN MAKE THEM VERY DIFFICULT
FOR- THE SPIRIT COURT JUDGE TO
HANDLE ON THE NORMAL DOCKET.
THEY ARE TEND TO HAVE A VERY
LARGE NUMBER OF PARTIES I'M
RANGING FROM. SIX OR SEVEN IN A
RELATIVELY SIMPLE CASE TO
HUNDREDS OR OF OR THOUSANDS. IN
A THE ADJUDICATION OF A
GROUNDWATER BASINS SUCH AS- THE
ONES I'VE PARTICIPATED IN- IN
THE SANTA MARIA AREA ON THE
CENTRAL COAST IN THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY IN EASTERN. A LOS ANGELES
AREA AND THEN- THE SALINAS- BASS
AND ALSO N THE CENTRAL COAST
YOU SEE HUNDREDS OF PARTIES AND
IT'S- OBVIOUSLY VERY DIFFICULT
TO MANAGE THAT WITHIN A NORMAL.
COURT CASE- THE ISSUES WATER
CASES PRESENT TEND TO BE VERY
TECHNICAL. SO YOU HAVE HUNDREDS
OF PARTIES AND THEN YOU LAY ON
TOP OF THAT- REALLY COMPETING
EXPERTS DEBATING ALL SORTS OF-
TECHNICAL THINGS SUCH AS HOW
MUCH WATER PERCOLATES INTO A
GROUNDWATER BASIN ON AVERAGE.
AND HOW MUCH- EXTRACTION OCCURS
IT'S NOT SIMPLE TO CALCULATE
THOSE THINGS SO THE JUDGE HAS TO
MANAGE LARGE NUMBERS OF EXPERTS
AS WELL IN MANY OF THESE CASES.
AND THEN AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
INDICATED. MANY OF THESE CASES
ARE VERY DOCUMENT HEAVY IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE- LITIGATION
INVOLVING HUNDREDS OF LANDOWNERS
HAVING TO PROVE UP- HOW MUCH
GROUND WATER THEY MAY HAVE
PUMPED OVER TIME. VERY DOCUMENT
HEAVY- AS THE BAY DELTA
LITIGATION AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM INDICATED THAT DIDN'T
INVOLVE WITNESSES BUT IT HAD TO
INVOLVE THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
PROCEEDING. THAT HAD LASTED FOR
YEARS AND SO YOU HAD TENS TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD ALL OF THIS MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE TO HANDLE ON A NORMAL
DOCKET SO. THE CONCEPT OF THE
STATE HAVING A PROGRAM TO UNDER
WHICH JUDGES CAN BE TRAINED AS
TO WHAT ISSUES ARISE AND HOW TO
HANDLE THEM IN THE KINDS OF
CASES IS A VERY GOOD IDEA. THEN
THOSE JUDGES THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HAVING THE ABILITY TO
ASSIGN CASES TO JUDGES WHO HAVE
THAT TRAINING- SHOULD. OF THOSE
JUDGES PROCESS THESE CASES AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD- AND THEN
FINALLY THE STATE PROVIDING SOME
SUPPORT. FOR EXPERT ASSISTANCE
IN THESE CASES ALSO MAKES VERY
GOOD SENSE AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM INDICATED MANY OF THEM ALL
OFTEN INVOLVES WHOLE REGIONS.
WATER SUPPLIES AND SO THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC INTEREST IN
ENSURING THAT THESE CASES
PROCEED- BOTH EFFICIENTLY AND
WELL SO THE BILL MAKES A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE LAW
THAT I THINK- WOULD. HELP THE
STATE AS A WHOLE. THANK YOU. OR
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONEWHO WOULD LIKE
TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRPERSON PORT OF AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I WILL GO FIRST TO LINE OF
NUMBER. TWENTY EIGHT ONE TWENTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES WITH THE SUPPORT
OF PERMANENT POSITION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
CONTINUING A GOOD DIALOGUE- WITH
THE ALTERNATE STAFF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THEN ONE MOMENT
MISTER WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ONE
COMING UP AS WE SPEAK. WE'RE
GOING NOW LINE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE. FINALLY TWENTY FIVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THE CAPITA TELEKINETIC POLIQUIN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOUR SUPPORT.
RESEARCHERS ACCUSE NOW QUICKER
pANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ONCE AGAIN SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
START. THIS YEAR WE HAVE NO
RESPONDENTS ACU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMA. CIGNA
MISTER GLOOMY MAY CLOSE MISTER
CHAIR SPECTRALLY ASCARI VOTE
THANK YOU AND WE WILL TAKE THIS
UP ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM. IF
RIGHT MISTER DALY MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE.
MORNING SO WERE. THE STAFF HAS
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH YOUR STAFF
MISTER CHAIR. ON THIS BILL AND
YOUR STAFF SUGGESTED EXPANDING
AT. THE BILL WAS FOCUSED ON CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS NOW THE
BILL EXPANDS THE EXISTING
ADDRESS CONFIDENTIALITY PROGRAM
TO ANYONE WHO FACES VIOLENCE OR
THREATS OF VIOLENCE BECAUSE OF
THEIR WORK EMPLOYMENT OR
VOLUNTEER SERVICE- THIS WILL
INCLUDE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
ELECTION VOLUNTEERS SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS AND CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS JUST TO NAME A FEW. BY
BROADENING THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY PROGRAM WE ARE
ENHANCING THE SAFETY OF THEM
SUBJECTED TO VIOLENCE AT WORK- I
HAVE. GOOD MORNING- DOROTHY
JOHNSON WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IS HERE TO SPEAK ON THE BILL IN
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS ON
A SANTIAGO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHICH IS WHERE THE BILL
STARTED BUT NOW IT'S BEEN
BROADENED AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF
BECAUSE I THINK THE BROADENING
MAKES. GOOD SENSE. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIRST WITNESS PLEASE A
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS DOROTHY JOHNSON OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS PLEASED TO BE
HERE. MENTIONED THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND AN EXISTING OPTIONAL TOOL
TO HELP SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
HARASSMENT OR THREATS OR EVEN
ACTS OF VIOLENCE BECAUSE OF
THEIR WORKPLACE RESPONSIBILITY
ACTS THAT REPRESENTS THE VOICE
OF OUR SCHOOL LEADERS ARE
PRINCIPLES ARE SUPERINTENDENTS
AND OTHER SCHOOL SITE
ADMINISTRATORS AND REGRETTABLY
SOME SCHOOL LEADERS HAVE BEEN
THE TARGET OF SUCH- ANGER
FRUSTRATION AND FEAR BECAUSE OF
THEIR ENFORCEMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH MANDATES- AT SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. LEVINE ON OVER THE
PAST THREE SCHOOL YEARS SO- IN
AND AGAIN REGRETTABLY AND
SOMEONE SAYS THIS IS FILE THEM
NOT ONLY FROM THEIR CAMPUSES BUT
TO THEIR PERSONAL PRIVATE HOMES
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE THINK
EXTENDING THE SAFE AT HOME
PROGRAM TO OUR SCHOOL OFFICIALS
IS AN APPROPRIATE AND REASONABLE
CHANGE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I. ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THEN WE DO HAVE A WITNESS ON THE
TELEPHONE ON THE SANTIAGO ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I AM GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EMMA SANTIAGO AND I
AM A CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN
THE BAY AREA AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY ENSURE AN ABBREVIATED
PERSONAL ACCOUNT OF WHY AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE IS
NECESSARY AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
IN FEBRUARY LAST YEAR DURING THE
HEIGHT OF CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
I RESPONDED TO A REQUEST FROM A
RESTAURANT OWNER TO MEET IN
PERSON AT HIS PLACE OF BUSINESS
TO DISCUSS THE LETTER I HAD
DISTRIBUTED PERTAINING TO MATH
REGULATIONS. AB FIRST THE ONLY.
WITH FRIENDLY WELCOMING IN AND
THEN ONCE IN. THINGS TO A DARK
IN TO TURN. I WOULD HELD AGAINST
MY WILL FOR NEW AN HOUR. FROM
THE BEGINNING SO FELT WRONG AS
HE SAT ME UP THE TAPE FOR THE
BLOCK ME A- I BEGAN TO CONSIDER
THE DANGER OF THE SITUATION BUT
IT TEMPTED TO REMAIN CALM AND
FOCUS ON THE CONTENT OF THE
LETTER. HE BEGAN TOURING RAJAN
VERY UNNERVING BEHAVIOR SUCH AS
FORCING ME TO COUNT HIS TEACHER.
THE RATING ME ABOUT HIS
PERCEPTION OF MY RACE HE BECAME
ADAMANT THAT I DRANK A PREPARED
MET BEVERAGE THAT I PRESSED
CLOSE TO MY LOOK FOR FREE DID
HAVE. DROPPED DESPITE MY ATTEMPT
IN ASSURANCE THAT I WAS ONLY
THERE TO HELP HE BEGAN. HE
BECAME IRATE AND BEGAN
THREATENING ME WITH HIS MILITARY
EXPERIENCE. WITH THE DOOR STILL
FEELS LIKE WE BLOCKED I PICKED
UP MY CELLPHONE TO CALL FOR HELP
BUT I WAS TOLD TO PUT IT DOWN.
AT THIS POINT MY MIND WAS RACING
AND I WAS SCARED I TRIED TO
BRING HIM BACK AND I STATED THAT
I WAS ONLY THERE TO HELP THEM.
AND THAT THE LATTER IS MODIFYING
BUT ONLY TO LET HIM KNOW THAT
THAT WAS POSSIBLE. HE STOOD UP
WITH PROFANITY PROFANITY AND
TOLD ME TO GET OUT. I COULD NOT
GET OUT FAST ENOUGH BUT THE MAN
STOOD IN MY WAY AND RAMBLED
INCOHERENTLY AND THEN TURN ME.
WHAT THE COLD STARE AND THANK
YOU BETTER GET THE INFORMATION
TO ME BY MONDAY OR I WILL COME.
COME TO GET YOU OR GET A FROM
SOMEONE ELSE. EVEN IF I HAVE TO.
CONFRONT SOMEONE OUTSIDE
APOLOGIZE. LOOKS REALLY SCARED
ME A LITTLE COLD OOK OF NUMBER
MORE THE BEST WAY TO DESCRIBE
IT. AND SO I SAID OKAY I WOULD
AND THEN BOLTED. ON MY CAR GOT.
WENT BACK TO WORK INSTEAD OF
HOME. THE POLICE FOLLOWED UP
WITH THIS DEMAND HE THEM HE
WOULD BE BE IN THE HEAD OF HIS
ARMY AGAINST. I HAVE TWENTY FOUR
YEARS EXPERIENCE WITH CODE
FORSMAN AND I AM NO STRANGER TO
THREATS. BUT THIS MAN REALLY
SCARED ME. I HAVE OBTAINED OF
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER TO PROTECT ME IN THE CAR
OR AT WORK. THIS BILL WILL HELP
ME PROTECT ME AND MY FAMILY AT
HOME FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN HERE
WHO HAS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING CARLOS MACHADO WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT
SIGNAL OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT TO AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE WILL NOT
TAKE ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT-
WE WILL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. MISTER
CHAIR FOR SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE PRESS ONE ZERO
PLEASE AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
YOU HAVE A COUPLE KEEPING UP.
OKAY ONE MOMENT WELL THE FIRST
TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO ONE
TWENTY TWO GLOBAL AND PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING TURN NUMBERS BRADY
GARDEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. CEMEX IS
ONE NUMBER THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING. CALLING
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES THE CALIFORNIA
AND THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCT THE PORT. ONE MOMENT
MISTER BILL ONE MORE OF COMING
IN LATE. JUST A MOMENT.
HELLO THE LINE NUMBER. TWENTY
SIX ONE TWENTY SIX GOING TO
START. GOOD MORNING AT THE
BRYANT DELIVER THE CALIBER STATE
THAT THE OF COUNTIES THANK.
THANK YOU. IN THE CHEROKEE WAS
NOT. I THINK. TOOK BACK TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY IN THE
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE. OUR THANK YOU MR
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR OF ARNOLD RESPONDENTS IF
YOU. I THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MISTER
DAILY THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING
WITH US IT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THAT. GRANTING PROTECTIONS FOR A
CLASS OF EMPLOYEES JUST TO GRAB
THEM PROTECTIONS DIDN'T REALLY
MAKE SENSE BUT YOU RAISE A VERY
GOOD ISSUE. AND IF THERE IS ANY
INDICATION THAT AN INDIVIDUAL OR
A CLASS BECAUSE OF CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. NEEDS A LEVEL OF
PROTECTION I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
A VERY LEGITIMATE REQUEST AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE REALLY TRIED
TO ADDRESS HERE SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRING IN THE BILL FORD AND
WORKING WITH WITH ASSIGNMENTS.
MR STONE I THINK THAT YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE- FAIRLY NARROW
BILL MAKES GREAT SENSE BECAUSE
THE TIMES WHERE AND SO I
APPRECIATE. YOUR SUGGESTIONS AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORK. AND
I'M PREPARED TO ASK YOU ALL TO
SUPPORT THE- THE BILL THAT'S
BEEN IT'S BEEN EXPANDED AND- I
HOPE. IT SUCCEEDS AT A HIGH DUE
TO IT OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
. YOU MAY CLOSE OR WE CAN TAKE
THAT ISSUE CLOSE I WILL
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE ONCE YEAR
QUORUM ARRIVES THANK YOU. ONCE
WE GET A QUORUM YEAH AT SOME
POINT WE WILL THANK YOU MR OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY SIR MISTER
COOPER WILL NOW MOVE TIED NUMBER
THREE AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN.
OKAY SORRY.
WHICH IS FILLED WITH. PARDON
BETWEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FOR YOUR OKAY YOU ARE PERFECT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES IT'S FOOD IMPORTERS
ARE GENERALLY EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
BEEN PROMOTED TO SUPERVISOR
MANAGEMENT LEVEL IN MANY
INSTANCES ONE SIMPLY PROMOTES
THEY LOSE MANY PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE ENJOYED BY REPRESENT
EMPLOYEES. MONIES PROTECTIONS
BINDING ARBITRATION EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER GRIEVANCES WHEN BINDING
ARBITRATION IS USED IT PERMITS
DISPUTES TO BE RESOLVED QUICKLY
ELAM AT MUCH LOWER COST TO THE
EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOYER WAS NOT
USE THOSE BOOTS ARE TIME
CONSUMING COSTLY AND UNBALANCED
A. B. SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN WILL
INCLUDE BINDING ARBITRATION IN
THE SLOUGH EMPLOYEE BILL OF
RIGHTS. THIS ALLOWED THROUGH
EMPLOYEES TO REQUEST ARBITRATION
ACTORS OFTEN THE NORMAL MULTI
LEVEL GRIEVANCE PROCESS AND ONCE
IN A BY STATE AGENCIES TO MAKE
FAIR AND ETHICAL DECISIONS ON
EMPLOYEE GRIEVANCES WITH ME
TODAY IS FORTUNATE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA.
CORRECTIONAL SURPRISED
DISASSOCIATION. ONE FIRST WITH
THE MORE MISTER CHAIR AND CA
MET- MY NAME IS FORD CANNOT-
MINISTRY OF REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION. WE
REPRESENT SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS AND DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS IN AN APARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS. OF THIS BILL
IS. OF ALMOST EVERY SUPERVISED
STATE SUPERVISOR ROGER ONCE THIS
BILL TO PASS. UP BECAUSE- OUR
OUR GRIEVANCE SYSTEM IS BROKEN
IT IT DOESN'T WORK- VALLEY-
DENIES A 100% OF OUR GRIEVANCES
THAT I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS I'VE NEVER
SEEN A GRANTED. GRIEVANCE FROM
CALAIS CHART EVER. A DIRECT I'M
GOING BACK INTO THE EIGHTIES ON
THIS AND- THE ISSUE IS THAT-
THEY DENY EVERYTHING AND THEN
THE SEND OF SOFT INTO SUPERIOR
COURT TO TRY TO FIX THINGS WHICH
TAKES A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND YEARS OF TIME FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE ONE CASE THAT IS THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD WERE WINNING THE CASE
WE WENT ALL THE WAY TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CAME
BACK DOWN AND NOW THEY'RE TRYING
TO DECIPHER HOW MUCH THEY OWE
AS- IF THEY WERE JUST TO PAY
EACH SUPERVISOR. THIS CALL THE
WHAT TIME CASE ONE HOUR OF
OVERTIME PER WEEK. THEY WOULD
ALL ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THIS THAT'S ONE
CASE OF WE HAVE TWO OTHER CASES
THAT E GOT GOING ON WE DON'T
LIKE GOING TO SUPERIOR COURT WE
DON'T- I KNOW OUR LAWYERS LOVE
IT AND I DON'T THE STATE LAWYERS
LOVE IT. THEY'LL MAKE MONEY OFF
THESE CASES. BUT WE CAN RESOLVE
THESE THINGS IN FORTY FIVE DAYS.
NOT THIRTEEN YEARS OR FIVE YEARS
OR WHATEVER A LOT OF THE
PLAINTIFFS HAVE OF GROWN OLD AND
DIED. OF TRYING TO GET A
RESOLUTION ON THESE ISSUES OF
YOU HAVE TWENTY ONE BARGAINING
UNITS THAT HAVE ARBITRATION
RIGHTS. YOU DON'T SEE ANY THESE-
RANK AND FILE ORGANIZATIONS
VIOLIN IN SUPERIOR COURT COSTING
THE STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LITIGATION. THE ONLY PEOPLE YOU
SEE IN SUPERIOR COURT OR THE
SUPERVISORS WHY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME THING THAT
THE- RANK AND FILE HAVE WHICH IS
ARBITRATION RIGHTS. AND THE
ISSUE OF- CAL HR- HAS
MISINFORMED THE GOVERNOR
REPEATEDLY I THINK THE LAST VETO
MESSAGE SAID WE CAN GO TO OF
STATE PERSONNEL BOARD OR- FARE-
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING. FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING IS THE
ECO ISSUE. STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
IS FOR MERIT ISSUES IN
DISCIPLINARY ISSUES. THE
ARBITRATION THE BILL IS FOR
WORKING CONDITIONS AND PAY YES
WE'VE WE CAN'T GO TO EITHER ONE
OF THOSE DEALS EVEN THOUGH THAT
WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S MESSAGE
WHAT IT BECAUSE HE WAS
MISINFORMED BY CAL HR WHO DOES
NOT WANT US TO HAVE. ARBITRATION
RIGHTS BECAUSE ALL THEY HAVE TO
DO IS DENY OUR GRIEVANCES
INCENTIVES OFF TO SUPERIOR COURT
. ED IT DOESN'T DO ANYBODY ANY
GOOD FOR US TO SPEND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN YEARS OF LITIGATION
ON SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
RESOLVED IN FORTY FIVE DAYS FOR
FORTY THOUSAND. AND WE ALSO
THANK YOU TAYLOR THIS OUR ENERGY
TO WRAP UP PLEASE BILL. WITH A
SUNSET CLAUSE WHICH MEANS IT'LL
ONLY BE IN EFFECT FOR FIVE YEARS
TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE GOVERNOR
AND STATE GOVERNMENT THAT IT
DOES SAVE A LOT OF MONEY IT DOES
HELP EVERYBODY. TO DO IT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB SEVENTEEN
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TO VOICE YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE SOME DIFFERENT LEVELS
ARE EXTERNAL WITH HEADLINERS.
IN THIRTY EIGHT AIRLINES OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THE BAKER WITH
ERIC REID ASSOCIATES FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY A
LINE OF THIRTY SIX ONE MOMENT
WE'LL GET THE QUEUED UP. ONE
THIRTY SIX TWO OAKLAND POLICE.
THE OR GOOD MORNING
CHARLOTTESVILLE SB THIRTY OF
CALIFORNIA STATE TO PROVIDE
THEIR SUPPORT. I KNOW IT'S WITH
A LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GONNA
. MISTER CHAIRMAN RESPECT BRAND
WITH THEIR IN RING A SO
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS CAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHEROKEE WITH NOW QUICKER ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU BILL NOW MOVES
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN. RIGHT SIGNAL
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN. PROPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IT'S. MISTER CHAIR THAT
PROFIT MORE RESPONDENTS IN Q. I
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SCOUR. I THINK HE WAS
CHARGED YOU KNOW LOOKING AT THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE- SAYING
THAT THIS WOULD HAVE COST WHICH
SEEMS KIND OF FLY IN THE FACE OF
THE FACT THAT THIS IS ALREADY
COSTING US. A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY
SO. AS- AS SOMEONE HAS GOTTEN
HAD MANY VETS BILLS VETOED
BEFORE I CAN ALWAYS UNDERSTAND-
WHAT THE REASONING IS I JUST
HOPE THAT WHATEVER ISSUE THERE
IS WITH THE MINISTRATIONS
RESOLVED BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY A VERY LOGICAL.
OF A WAY IN WHICH WE CAN CREATE
A MUCH MORE EFFICIENT. SYSTEM
THAT WOULD BE LESS COSTLY AND
MORE JUST NOT HAVING. OF THE
SUPERVISORS MANAGERS HAVE TO
WAIT IN SOME CASES MANY YEARS
RESOLUTION SO WHEN WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY WILL CERTAINLY
SUPPORT. THE BILL THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
PLEASE HOLD- ON JUST A QUESTION
AS IT RELATES TO. THE PROCESS
WAS THIS A- WAS A SUBJECT TO OR
COULD HAVE BEEN PART OF- MO YOU
NEGOTIATED. POINT TO BE IN A CAR
TO BE IN YOUR. NO WORSE. I'M
JUST THE QUESTION A WHETHER THIS
WAS A NEGOTIATED YOU'RE TEMPTED
TEGEN NEGOTIATE THIS OR WAS THIS
AN ELEMENT THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATING TO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE EMPLOYEES
THEN THEIR- A BARGAINING
SUPERVISORS DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE. WE HAVE WE
WE'RE UNDER THE OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE ENTITLED TO OF
REGULATIONS AND- WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY- THAT'S WHAT
EXCLUDED MEANS EXCLUDED EMPLOYEE
IS SOMEONE WHO. IS NOT COVERED
UNDER CONTRACTS YOU GOT TWENTY
ONE CONTRACTS. TWO HUNDRED AND
SOME THOUSAND RANK AND FILE IN
ONLY ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
SUPERVISORS IN THE STATE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SYNONYMOUS TO COOPER
YOU MAY CLOSE AT THE OLYMPIC
MEMBERS THEIR COMMENTS WE'VE GOT
TWENTY ONE BAR UNITS THAT THE
MAJORITY THE VAST MAJORITY STATE
EMPLOYEES HAVE BINDING
ARBITRATION- IT'S A LOT CHEAPER
OBVIOUSLY THE CAT AT THE GROCERY
THAN GO TO SUPERIOR COURT AT
SUPERIOR COURT CAN DRAG OUT THE
KOSTER- TREMENDOUS- SO I THINK
IT IT MAKES SENSE IT IT'S AND
KELLY CHARS BILLION PAYMENT A
LOT OF ISSUES NOT JUST THIS- SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL TAKE IT UP
ONCE WE GET A QUORUM. THANK YOU
. HE WILL MOVE TO OUR ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE MR GABRIEL.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED 2% AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN THE
SARGENT SHRIVER CIVIL COUNCIL
ACT. THE SHRIVER PROGRAM
PROVIDES LEGAL REPRESENTATION TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN HIGH
STAKES CIVIL MATTERS IMPACTING
BASIC HUMAN NEEDS SUCH AS CHILD
CUSTODY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
EVICTION PROCEEDINGS. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED INTO LAW AB THREE THIRTY
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED THE TRIBE
OR PROGRAM SOTHAT MORE
CALIFORNIANS CAN BE A SHORT OF
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THROUGH THE LEGAL SYSTEM. THIS
BILL BUILDS ON THAT PROGRESS BY
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT AL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
UNDER THE TRIBAL PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS ARE
CURRENTLY UNABLE TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION TO UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE OF
CONDITIONS ATTACHED TO FEDERAL
FUNDING. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
HELP THAT INJUSTICE BY REQUIRING
THESE ORGANIZATIONS TO REFER
IMMIGRANTS FOR SERVICES
ELSEWHERE IF THEY ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM ON THEIR OWN. THIS
IS A REQUIREMENT THAT IS BOTH
MORAL AND DEEPLY PRACTICAL
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN OUR
UNDOCUMENTED NEIGHBORS WHO ARE
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING DENIED-RELIEF PROVIDED TO OTHER FOLKS
AND THEREFORE MORE LIKELY TO BE
A NIGHT OF EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
SERVICES PROVIDED UNDER THE
SHRIVER PROGRAM. AND I WOULD YOU
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE. ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL- ONE OF THE FIRST
PRO BONO MATTERS THAT I HANDLE
THIS YOUNG ATTORNEY I THINK
ACTUALLY MAY HAVE BEEN THE
FIRST. IS REPRESENTING THE
VICTIMS OF. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHO WAS UNDOCUMENTED. AND HER
ABUSER WAS A CITIZEN. AND IT WAS
VERY EYE OPENING TO SEE THE
VULNERABILITY THAT SHE
EXPERIENCE THE WAY THAT HER
ABUSER SOUGHT TO LEVERAGE- THE
DISPARITY IN THEIR STATUS
AGAINST HER TO TRY TO DISCOURAGE
HER FROM SEEKING RELIEF THROUGH
THE COURTS- AND IT WOULD JUST.
REALLY IMPRESSED UPON ME HOW- AS
WE THINK ABOUT IT. CALIFORNIANS
WERE EXPLOITED WHO LACK POWER-
ARE ARE UNDOCUMENTED. FRIENDS
AND NEIGHBORS ARE AT THE VERY
TOP OF THAT LIST- BECAUSE THEY
OFTEN LACK POWER FOR MULTIPLE
REASONS AND SO- YOU KNOW WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE FOLKS IN
WASHINGTON WHO. MADE A POLICY
DECISION TO TRY TO DENY LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO THE MOST
WONDERFUL CALIFORNIANS BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE TO REINFORCE
THAT DECISION AND I THINK USING
WITH THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE ON
SHRIVER- AND HOPEFULLY WITH THIS
LEGISLATION WE CAN. DIRECT LEGAL
SERVICES TO THOSE WHO NEED IT
MOST- SO WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME-
AND WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IS SKIP
CANING THE DIRECTOR OF PRO BONO
SERVICES AT AND NEIGHBORHOOD
LEGAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THANK YOU I
BELIEVE MR CANNINGS WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE ARE YOU HERE. M.
LEDERLE. THANK YOU- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SKIP PANIC
OF THE DIRECTOR PRO BONO ONE
POLICY ADVOCACY AT NEIGHBORHOOD
LEGAL SERVICES OF L. A. COUNTY
AND I'M PLEASED TO PROVIDE
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY THREE WHICH WILL HELP
TO PROVIDE FREE LEGAL SERVICES
TO LOW INCOME LITIGANTS IN
CALIFORNIA REGARDING. YOUR LEGAL
STATUS. ANALYSTS IS THE LEAD
AGENCY OFFICIAL EVER HOUSING
PROJECT IN THE CENTRAL
COURTHOUSE IN LOS ANGELES. AND
IN THAT CAPACITY WE'VE SEEN THE
BENEFITS OF THE SHRIVER PROJECT
TO LOW INCOME RESIDENTS OF LA
COUNTY. A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
BELIEVE ORGANIZATIONS FUNDED
THROUGH THE SARGENT SHRIVER
CIVIL COUNCIL ACT ARE LEGALLY TO
LIKE AND I'LL ASK THAT RECEIVED
FUNDING THROUGH THE FEDERAL
LEGAL SERVICES CORPORATION. WELL
LSC FUNDING IS BEEN CRITICAL IN
HELPING ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY LEGAL
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY. IT DOES COME WITH
RESTRICTIONS THAT PREVENT US
FROM PROVIDING LEGAL AID IN SOME
CASES TO UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
. WELL IT'LL HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE LEGAL AID TO
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN
CERTAIN CASES WHICH IS BLENDED
FAMILIES ARE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THEIR CLIENTS WE HAVE
TO REFER TO ONE OF OUR NON LSC
FUNDED PARTNERS. IN THOSE CASES
THE WHOLE WARM HAND OFF TO A
TRUSTED PARTNER WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THE CLIENT RECEIVES THE
HIGHEST DEGREE OF LEGAL SERVICES
. BY REQUIRING LEGAL AID
PROGRAMS UNDER THE SHRIVER AFTER
REFER CLIENTS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY
FOR ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
SHRIVER PROJECT. TO OUR SISTER
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS. AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE WILL
PROTECT SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND HELP
TO CLOSE THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
GAP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE.
THING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TO VOICE AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THE NEW
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. ALREADY BY NUMBER NINETEEN
SCORE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JOHN
CAN GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ON STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN THE VOICE
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL RESPONDENTS IN Q. I
THANK YOU OPERATOR WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
LIKE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER PROPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE RESPONDENTS
HAVE QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF READY MADE
CLOTHES ALLIANCE AND I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMON. MISTRESS THANK
YOU MISTER I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS FOR THIS BILL I KNOW
THAT- MY VOLUNTEER WORK WITH THE
INLAND EMPIRE LATINO LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION- ALSO SHOWED ME THAT
THIS WAS A PROBLEM- A LOT OF IT
HAD TO DO WITH HOW WE REPORTED
THAT- SO THERE WERE SO MANY
DIFFERENT REPORTS ARE PREPARED
MARCH SECOND OF DIRECTOR BECAUSE
THERE WERE THERE WAS FUNDING
THAT WAS RESTRICTED THE DIDN'T
ALLOW. OUR THE VOLUNTEER
ATTORNEYS OR OUR STAFF ARE TO
SERVE THE UNDOCUMENTED SO
THERE'S LOTS OF REPORTS THAT THE
FACT THAT SOME OF THE LEGAL
LATER A HAVE ACCESS TO REFER
THEM TO A TRUSTED- LEGAL AID I
THINK IT'S A GREAT THING BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THAT ONE OF THE AND
I'M SURE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS DONE BY THE OTHER LEGAL
AIDES AND- RECEIVING FUNDING
THAT TO RESTRICT THAT BUT THEM
RECEIVING OTHER FUNDING THAT
DOES ALLOW IT. AND JUST KEEPING
THE MONEY SEPARATE. BUT WHEN THE
TIME IS CORRECT I WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MATTER MAJORITY LEADER- AND YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY HAVE HAD LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS I'VE BEEN
SUCH A STRONG PROPONENT FOR
CALIFORNIA GETTING IN THE GAME
IN A MORE SIGNIFICANT WAY IN
FUNDING- IN IN PROVIDING
RSOURCES IN OUR BUDGET FOR
LEGAL AID SO THAT WE CONSERVE
OUR UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY. BUT
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THANK YOU AND THAT'S BEEN A
PRIORITY THIS COMMITTEE. I THINK
EVERY YEAR SINCE I'VE CHAIRED IT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO PUT MORE
MONEY ESPECIALLY ONCE THE-
FEDERALS. BACKED OFF OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR LEGAL AID SO
I APPRECIATE THAT ALL RIGHT
SCARILY MAY CLOSE YEAH I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THOSE ISSUES AND
FOR THE GREAT WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE- AND YOU KNOW THE WORK
THAT- THAT YOU HAVE. DONE ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER OP
THURS. MISSING AN OPPORTUNITY.
HOW MUCH CAR YOU DO HAVE A BILL
LET'S TAKE THAT OUT. SO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
TWENTY SIX
SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING REPRESENTS AND ACTS
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST. DFG H.
IS THE STATE'S LARGEST CIVIL
RIGHTS AGENCY WITH A MISSION TO
PREVENT UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION
AND PRACTICES AGAINST CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SPECIFICALLY. DLPH
ENGAGES INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING
COMPLAINTS OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
EMPLOYEES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION IN EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING AND PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AS
WELL AS HATE CRIMES AND TRAFFIC
AND- IN RECENT YEARS THE FBHS
BASE SOME CHALLENGES AND
DISPUTES REGARDING ITS AUTHORITY
AND ABILITY. THESE CHALLENGES
HAVE STATED THIS DEPARTMENT MAY
NOT REPRESENT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST WHEN ACTING ON BEHALF
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE BROUGHT
FORWARD COMPLAINTS HOWEVER.
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING PURSES CAPIZ
CREATIONS TWENTY TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEALS
AFFIRMED THAT DFG H. HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO ACT IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST SAYS THE DEPARTMENT HAS
THE RIGHT TO BRING CIVIL ACTION
THAT FITS THEIR ON GOING.
MISSION THIS BILL WOULD REMOVE
ANY AMBIGUITY REGARDING GST H.
AS ABILITY TO PROSECUTE CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC INTEREST. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IS LISTED OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO. SENA
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO. THE VOICE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THIS TIME. SH. WE'RE GONNA
ADELINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS JACQUI
TURN ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
I MISS RICHER WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL RESPONDENTS WHO Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY TWO. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO. HELLO TO
ALL THE PUBLIC FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. STRUCTURE WITH A PROFIT OF
NO RESPONDENTS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. YOU MAY CLOSE
ALLIANCE OPERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT NONE THIS CAR
YOU MAY CLOSE STEADFAST WE'E
NOT ABLE TO THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT. RIGHT
MISTER GIBSON WILL MOVE NOW TO
OUR ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
WILL ADD THE NEXT OF KIN TO
EXISTING LAW. CLEANING UP AND
CLARIFYING THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS WITH THOSE UNABLE TO
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THE PERSON WHOSE-
WHO'S A PATIENT- RECEIVE THE
BEST OF CARE- AND HAVING SOMEONE
THERE TO MAKE. GOOD STYLE
MEDICAL DECISIONS ON THEIR
BEHALF THIS BILL CLEANS UP
LANGUAGE IN CURRENT LAW. TO
REPRESENT THE CHANGING
DEFINITION OF FAMILY IN OUR
STATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT ADS- CLARITY. IN
CURRENT LAW TWO SECTIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY CONFUSING FOR
THOSE GOING THROUGH THE END OF
LIFE CARE FOR EXAMPLE. THERE IS
A SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD WOMAN
LIVING ALONE. SHE FALLS IN HER
HOME AND HITS HER HEAD ON THE
CORNER. HER CARE GIVER WHO
PROVIDES A WELLNESS CHECK AND
FEEDING HER ANIMALS FINDS HER
LAYING UNRESPONSIVE ON THE
FLOOR. TAKE HER TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM HER NURSE AND HER CARE TEAM
HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT THERE IS NO
ADVANCE DIRECTIVE. AT THIS TIME
IT IS UP TO THE DOCTORS OR HER A
CARE TEAM TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST
COURSE OF ACTION FOR HER. ONLY
ONE IN EVERY THREE ADULTS IN THE
UNITED STATES COMPLETES ANY TYPE
OF ADVANCE DIRECTIVE FOR THE END
OF LIFE HEALTH CARE CURRENTLY
LOS CURRENT LAW. CAN DO A BETTER
JOB IN MAKING SURE THAT PERSONS
WITH PATIENTS BEST INTERESTS AT
HEART MAKE CRITICAL HEALTH
DECISIONS. THE NEXT OF KIN IS
NOT ALWAYS THE NEXT OF KIN. IN
SOME CASES IT'S A FRIEND A CARE
GIVER DOMESTIC PARTNER WHO MAKES
UP OUR FAMILY. ONE THING THAT WE
HAVE TO LEARN WHILE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH PATIENT ORIENTED CARE
IS THAT NOT ALL FAMILY MEMBERS
COME IN ONE SIZE OR FLAVOR. ARE
MEMBERS OF THE AGING COMMUNITY
EXPRESSLY THOSE IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ARE OFTEN FORCED TO BE
ALONE DURING THE LACK OF SUPPORT
THIS POPULATION HAS ALSO BEEN
ONE OF THE MOST ISOLATED DURING
THE PANDEMIC THE VERY PERSONAL
AND SENSITIVE SITUATION THAT WE
GO THROUGH DURING TIMES OF
ILLNESS. AND EMERGENCIES MUST BE
TREATED WITH CARE AND WITH
RESPECT THE LACK OF ADVANCE
DIRECTIVES PUT A BURDEN ON
PATIENTS. FAMILIES HOSPITALS AND
EXPRESSLY. ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
ALREADY DEAL WITH ENOUGH
PROBLEMS THAT THEY FACE AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT ALLOWS
FAMILIES TO DO WHAT WORKS FOR
THEM PUBLIC HEALTH HAS SHOWN US
THAT PEOPLE CENTRED CARE IS THE
BEST WY TO RESPECT PATIENTS IN
AND OUT OF CRITICAL CONDITIONS
JOINING ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY BY PHONE OR TO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE WHO WAS SELF
INTRODUCE. I THANK YOU I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES. INDICATED FROM
THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE GENE
DORIA AND ROBIN CLOUGH. JEAN
DORIA ORACLE ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JEAN GO OREO AND I AM A
GERIATRIC POSITION FROM SANTA
CLARITA PROVIDING HOUSE CALLED
THE NURSING HOME CARE TO OLDER
ADULTS AND DISABLED FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND IN THE PAST HAVE BEEN CHAIR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF MEDICINE
FOR THREE YEARS. AT A LOCAL
HOSPITAL I COME TO YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PROPOSED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE GIPSON.
THREE YEARS AGO AS CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOSPITAL ETHICS COMMITTEE
AND EMERGENCY CASES BROUGHT
BEFORE US WHAT FAMILY REQUESTING
THEY MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS FOR
THEIR HOSPITALIZED LOVED ONES.
THE PATIENT WAS ADMITTED
UNCONSCIOUS ANDWHAT'S IN THE
ICU ON A VENTILATOR HE DID NOT
HAVE THE ADVANCE DIRECTIVE NORTH
PINE LEGAL PAPERWORK A POWER OF
ATTORNEY DESIGNATING. WHO WOULD
BE IS CHOSEN MEDICAL DECISION
MAKER ATTORNEY GENERAL HOSPITAL
AN HMO WHAT PRESIDENT REQUESTING
THAT THEY BE GIVEN THE RIGHT TO
DISCONNECT THE VENTILATOR WHICH
THEY ARGUED WAS CALIFORNIA LAW
INDEED. THEN AND NOW THEY ARE
CORRECT. THE FAMILY INCLUDING
WIFE AND THREE ADULT CHILDREN
REQUESTED THAT MEXICAN BABY
ALLOWED TO MAKE MEDICAL
DECISIONS FOR THEIR LOVED ONES
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
WELL ADD MEXICAN THE CALIFORNIA
LAW PROTECTING THE RIGHT THE
FAMILY. WHAT IT REMOVES THE
THREAT OF HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATORS AND HMO BUSINESS
PEOPLE THREATENING THE TAKE
QUICK RIGHT A MEDICAL DECISION
MAKING FROM FAMILY MEMBERS THE
HOSPITAL DID NOT. DISCONNECT THE
PATIENT FROM THE VENTILATOR OF
BANK THREE PM CREW AND WAS ABLE
TO WALK OUT OF THE HOSPITAL AND
RETURN HOME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND IS ROBIN CLOUGH WITH US
ON THE PHONE. YES I AM A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRPERSON
COMMITTEE MEMBER- MY NAME IS
ROBIN CLOUD I WORK AT THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY SENIOR CENTER
WHERE WE PROVIDE ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT OF CARE FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND DISABLED IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND I. COME TO YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PROPOSED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE GIPSON AND
I SPEAK AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
PRESENT CALIFORNIA LAW
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO ADULTS
WHO DO NOT HAVE AN ADVANCE
DIRECTIVE OR A POWER OF ATTORNEY
AND MIGHT BE UNCONSCIOUS ON
HOSPITAL ADMISSION. IT WOULD
PROTECT PATIENTS AND NEXT THAT
CAN ALLOWING OUR NEXT OF KIN TO
BE DESIGNATED AT THE MEDICAL
DECISION MAKERS AS THEY SHOULD.
FORTY SIX OF FIFTY ONE STATES
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA ALREADY HAVE SIMILAR
DESIGNATION OF NEXT OF KIN IN
THEIR LAW THEY REALIZE ITS
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE. AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT WOULD BRING
CALIFORNIA LAW INTO ALIGNMENT.
WITH OTHER STATE. MULTIPLE IT
WILL ENSURE MEDICAL DECISION
MAKING REMAINS IN THE OF. AND
THEIR NECKS OF KIN. AND A
POTENTIAL BY HOT ADMINISTRATORS
ADMINISTRATORS OR MEDICAL
BUSINESS PEOPLE THE THOUGHT IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT IS WHY I
WOULD LIKE YOUR SUPPORT WITH A.
B. TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OR
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING TONY
TICKET TELL EM BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND WHAT ELSE. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OKAY
ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO LIKED
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRPERSON SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME THE MOBILE
FIRST THE LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX
NINE POINT SIX WAS GOING TO.
GOOD MORNING MSTER CHAIR HI
THIS IS JOHN FOR YOUR- SHORT
RULES COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE. SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT SIMPLY S. NEXT
CHANCE TO THE PARTS OF LAW IN
THE FLIGHTS THAT. FORTY SIX
FIFTY ONE THIRTEEN THE DISTRICT
OF COLUMBIA HAVE LAWS WHICH
INCLUDES. EXCEPT HERE. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. SB. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU TEXAS HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE NINE THIRTY NINE IT'S GONNA
. OKAY A NUMBER IS SIX A MISSION
J. AND MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE AND I SUPPORT
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
THANKS OF LINE FORTY TWO ONE
FORTY TO PRESERVE. MY NAME IS
TONY GET I'M A MEMBER OF THE
STATE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE I SUPPORT AB TWO
THREE THREE EIGHT IT SIMPLY ADDS
NEXT OF KIN TO THE THANK YOUNG
LAW THANK YOU FORTY TWO STATES
WHERE. THERE WERE NOT GOING TO
TAKE A TESTIMONY JUST AN
INDICATION OF. SO NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. THANKS
OF ONE FORTY FIVE IS GOING ON.
THIRTY ONE POINT FORTY TO
APOLOGIZE ONE FORTY TWO FISCAL.
I JUST WENT AHEAD AND CAN DO IT
AGAIN I SUPPORT A. B. YOUR BILL
THREE TWENTY FROM WESTLAKE.
WE'RE GOING 214-039-1403
EMPLOYEES. MY NAME IS TANYA WENT
ON. AND SUPPORT AS A TWO THREE
THIRTY EIGHT I AM A PRIVATE.
THANK YOU ALL. I'M NOT LINES GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THEODORE
SMITH A. K. A. PAT SMITH I'M A
CALIFORNIA'S SENIOR SENATOR AND
I STRONGLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO DOWN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KAREN CORR BATHROOM THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND I SUPPORT AB. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
WITHOUT THE KEY WAS NOW CLEAR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVED OPPOSITION I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HERE. CUNNINGHAM
DAVIES HOLDEN. KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. FRIEDMAN
WICKS THANK YOU BUT WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AND
WORKS FOR JOINING US TODAY
FILLING A COUPLE OF VACANCIES.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM HERE TO
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
YEAH GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
I CAME TO MEET HIM HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION-
WE'VE A BIT OF A NUANCED
APPROACH BUT APPRECIATE THE WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. WE HAVE
CONCERNS OF THE BILL IN PRINT
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT- AUTHORS
WORKING ON AMENDMENTS AND WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME OUR FIRST ONE UP IS
ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE COLLEGES LINE THIRTY FIVE
POINT STE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDON MARCHING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION-
IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION TO APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR
THUS FAR AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR THE QUEUES NOW
CLEAR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. A
PRETTY MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MISTER GIBSON YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY THREE- THIRTY EIGHTS-
GIVE GUIDANCE AND PEACE TO
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN NEED OF
MAKING HARD DECISIONS BY PUTTING
THE RIGHT PEOPLE AT THE TABLE IN
HELPING MAKING THOSE RIGHT
DECISIONS I PRAY FOR OTHER
FAMILIES WHO END UP IN A
SITUATION- NOT HAVING SOMEONE TO
MAKE THE DECISIONS THAT THEY
WISH. THAT SOMEONE WAS THERE TO
MAKE ON THEIR BEHALF- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE KALRA PLEASE STONE
AYE. STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
DAVIES DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN I
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN WICKS. THE NEEDS ONE
MORE TO WORK WITH THE BILL A
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. RIGHT THE TEXAS TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE OH TO
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
GOOD MORNING WHAT YEAR. MORNING
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ARE I'M HERE TODAY PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE OH TO A BILL THAT
HELPS IN THE LEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET BY INCREASING FINES FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO KNOWINGLY
PROVIDE SPACE FOR ILLEGAL
CANNABIS OPERATIONS I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE ASSISTANCE ON
THIS BILL AND I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU. STATE WHY
WE CONTINUE TO SEE A PROBLEM
WITH ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET NOT
ONLY DO THESE OPERATORS UNDERCUT
THE LEGAL MARKET BUT THEIR
OPERATION WHETHER CULTIVATION
MANUFACTURING OR RETAIL POSE A
GREAT THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND LOS ANGELES ALONE
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF CANADA'S
OPERATORS EXIST IN THE LEGAL
MARKET. THIS BILL PROVIDES
ANOTHER TOOL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SHUT DOWN THESE BUSINESSES BY
ASSESSING PIES OF PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO KNOWINGLY PERMIT.
THESE BUSINESSES TO OPERATE AB
TWENTY ONE OH TWO ASSESS IS A
CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS IN VIOLATION.
THE BILL SPECIFIED THAT THESE
FINES CAN BE LEVIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANVAS CONTROL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I VOTE TO CONTINUE EFFORTS
TO ELIMINATE ILLEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. WITH ME IN THE ROOM TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IT'S SYLVIA SO
LEASE SHAW REPRESENTING. THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES- FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. MR CHIU MEMBERS
SILVIUS SHOT HE ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE FEWER. A IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
THE AMENDS TAKEN TO THE BILL SO
AS FAR. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN SORRY THE
CITY IS ESTIMATED TO HAVE MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN HUNDRED ILLEGAL
CANNABIS OPERATORS. AND AS ALSO
MENTIONED NOT ONLY DO THESE
OPERATORS HURT LICENSED
OPERATORS. IN THE CITY BUT THEY
ALSO HURT HARM CONSUMERS BY
SELLING PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT
SCREENED APPROPRIATELY BY LABS
AND CAN POSE HEALTH RATE RISKS
TO THOSE CONSUMERS. AB TWENTY
ONE OUGHT TO WILL SERVE AS AN
IMPORTANT STATEWIDE TOOL TO
DISCOURAGE THE PROLIFERATION OF
THESE UNLICENSED OPERATORS AND
WE ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO. THANK
YOU AND IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT. GIVE
ME JUST A MOMENT HERE AS WE
GATHER. I NUMBER HERE. WE GOT A
LINE OF THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ARE GOOD BRING THE FUTURE
MEMBER COUNTY VAN OSTERN
REPRESENTING COOLEY THAT PICKED
OUT OF SAN JOSE AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AT NINE FURTHER AT THIS TIME. I
THINK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
ONE OH TWO. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES TO ANY OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWENTY ONE OH TWO. AND AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NONE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE
LIGHTS OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. MISTER
JOHN SORRY MAKE CLOSE
PERSPECTIVE AT SURVIVOR THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED. TO THE BNP COMMITTEE
CULTURAL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES DAVIES I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE KALRA. KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN WICKS. THE BILL IS OUT
RIGHT MISTER JONES ARE AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FIVE THANK YOU.
AGAIN I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE A
BILL THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
CANNABIS IS TREATED JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER LEGAL SUBSTANCE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF CHILD CUSTODY
DEPENDENCY COURT. AGAIN I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. AND I
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
OUR OFFICES HAD BEEN AWARE OF
INCIDENTS WHERE FAMILIES ARE
BROUGHT INTO DEPENDENCY COURTS
FOR THE MERE POSSESSION OF
ILLEGAL CANNABIS WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE OF CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS MERE
POSSESSION OF LEGAL CANNABIS IS
INSUFFICIENT TO TAKE CUSTODY OF
A FAMILY UNDER CASE LAW YET
STILL WE ARE AWARE OF SITUATIONS
WHERE FAMILIES ARE DRAGGED INTO
COURT MERELY DUE TO POSSESSION
OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS. TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL DOES NOT AND I REPEAT
DOES NOT MAKE ANY CHANGES TO THE
CHILD WELFARE INVESTIGATION
PROCESS OR ANY PROCEEDINGS. IT
ONLY REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OVERSEES INVESTIGATION TO ENSURE
THAT ALL REGULATIONS AND
GUIDANCE GIVEN TO COUNTIES
TREATS CANNABIS TO SAME AS
ALCOHOL OR LEGALLY PRESCRIBED
MEDICATION. DR FAMILIES INTO
COURT FOR POSSESSION OF CANNABIS
CANNABIS IS NOT ONLY A STRESSFUL
EVENT THAT REQUIRES TAKING TIME
OFF OF WORK FOR JUGGLING
SCHEDULES IT CAN BE INCREDIBLY
TRAUMATIC FOR CHILDREN. THIS
BILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
INVESTIGATORS STILL HAVE THE
TOOLS TO DETERMINE A COLLECT. OR
B. USE BUT DO NOT BURDEN
FAMILIES FOR THE LEGAL
POSSESSION OF CANNABIS WITH ME
TODAY TO PRESENT ON THE PHONE IS
BROKE HUGHLEY FROM THE LOS
ANGELES DEPENDENCY LAWYERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. RIGHT THE FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JULIE AND I'M A
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY AT LOS
ANGELES DEPENDENCY LAWYERS BUT
THE LARGEST ORGANIZATION OF OUR
KIND IN THE NATION AND WE
REPRESENT AROUND TWENTY THOUSAND
PARENTS AND THE CHILDREN COURT
ON ANY GIVEN DAY I'M PLEASED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES UPDATED INSTRUCTIONS.
RELATING TO CHILD NEGLECT
INVESTIGATION. INVOLVING
CANNABIS USE. I'M AND JUST
FACING THE CHILD SHOULD TODAY
INVOLVES THE- TREATMENT
APPARENTLY TH CANNABIS PURSUE
THEIR USE THAT ALCOHOL ARE
LEGALLY PRESCRIBED MEDICATION.
AS A MEMBER NOTED IN TWENTY
TWELVE THE COURT OF APPEAL HAS
CONSISTENTLY HELD THAT A PARENT
CANNABIS ALONE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT. FOR THE STATE TO
INTERFERE IN THE FAMILY DESPITE
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS IN THE
CHILDREN'S COURT I THINK
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES HOLD THROUGH THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. SOLELY BECAUSE
THE PARENT IS CANADA AT SOME
POINT. AND MANY OF THESE CASES
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF THE CHILD
EVERYTHING. AGREED ON THE
BLACKBOARD. IN FACT CLOUT IT'S
HEALTHY LAW. GOING TO. AND HOW
EVERYONE IF FEEL SAFE WITH THEIR
- THE REASON IS ARE BEING
DESTROYED IS IN TWO. MADE BY
SOCIAL MINISTRY. I PARA WILL BE
CLOSE CANNABIS USE AND MAY
WORKERS WILL SIMPLY. THAT THE
CHILD BEING THAT EVEN WITHOUT
ANY FACTS TO BACK THAT UP. WITH
WORD THE CONCERN AROUND CANADA
ARE OFF USES THE CREEPY TO AND-
HELLO AND CAN AND FAMILIES OF
COLOR. AS A RESULT OF THE AGENCY
DECISION THE CHILD CLASS. THE
TROUBLE AGENTS THE J. THE
FAMILIES THAT. PHONE CALLS ON
DROP AND INTERROGATE ACT.
UNDERTREATED LIKE CRIMINAL AND
IT'S THAT AND LASTLY TO DRUG
TESTS YOUR SON ALL THE WORKERS
CALL AND IT CAN THEIR SHOW. THE
CHILD BE K. AWAY AND COULDN'T
FOSTER CARE. I REMEMBER NOTED
PARENTS ARE AND WORK FAMILY
FUNCTION AT THIS AND THE ENTIRE
STAFF IS PUT IN A STATE OF
DISTRESS. KAREN AND THE CHILDREN
ARE LIVING IN TWO OF THE
INVOLVED. SEPARATE I TWENTY FIVE
NINE FIVE HELP TO A- THE ISSUE
BY ENSURING THAT THE FIRST
WORKERS ARE PROPER GUIDE. THAT
WAY AT. STAPLE USED. ITS TREE
WITH SAME AS A CAR WHICH- COULD
. ALCOHOL TAKES LEGALLY.
MEDICALLY ACCORDING ONLY. HELP
YOU. FOR ANOTHER SCRUTINY BUT-
WILL ALSO PREVENT THE WEIGHT OF
BIO RESOURCE. INVESTED IN THE
SCAM. OF THESE REASONS L. A.
DEPENDENT LAWYER EXPECT THAT THE
COURT EIGHTY. FIVE NINETY. THANK
YOU CHAIR IN SHE AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D TO SEE IN
SOME OF A. TWENTY NINETY FIVE.
ALL RIGHT SING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO. INDICATES
A FOR A BI TO FIVE NOW FIVE.
AGAIN IF LIKE TO SUPPORT PLEASE
ONE ZERO ACCESS TIME AGAIN AT.
ONE ZERO.
GIVE US JUST A MOMENT HERE. I
GET IT'S ONE ZERO WORKABLE LINE
OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI THIS IS ELLEN CONCRETE
CALIFORNIA NORMAL ON BEHALF OF
THE RESPONSIBLE CANNABIS USE IS
THE CALIFORNIA IN CONCORD. THANK
YOU. AND CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN
Q. I THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FIVE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE ARE
PRETTY WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FIVE. AND AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME IN OPPOSITION PLEASE IT'S
ONE ZERO.
AND HE'S GOING TO GO I'M SORRY
I'M ACTUALLY CALLING AT THE PORT
OF A. B. TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE
I WOULD THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL GROUPS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THANK YOU. I THANK YOU.
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BIZRATE'S. THANK
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. RIGHT MISTER JOHN
SORRY MAKE CLOSE PERSPECTIVE AS
PRIVATE THANK YOU THE MOTION
SECOND IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HUMAN SERVICES CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
. HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN WICKES WICKES I. THAT
NEEDS ONE MORE SO WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL I'LL CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER NINE A.
B. NINETEEN FORTY NINE MISTER
LOW. GEORGE.
STILL I WANT. GOOD MORNING MR
LOW- RON AB NINETEEN FORTY
NINETEEN FORTY NINE PLEASE BEGIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS THE
PREPAYMENT ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHICH WOULD HELP TO ENSURE
THAT WE PROVIDE UNPAID
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE TO INDIVIDUALS
ESPECIALLY IN THIS TIME OF NEED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE AND
HAVE KEVIN **** FROM THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS YOU'VE ON
TRIES FROM THE MOTHER'S. VOICE
GO AHEAD SIR. MORNING FOR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEN LANGONE
ON THE POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION YOU'RE ONE OF THE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY NINE ALONG WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. GOOD LUCK TO
ONCE AGAIN EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER LOW FIGURE
FOR THE SENSE AND PUSHING FOR
THE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS IN
THIS BILL AND ALSO FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
EXCELLENT OFFICE. THE TESTIMONY
THAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM A SECOND
WITNESS MISS YVONNE PRICE. IS A
DEVASTATING ACCOUNT FOR THE
HARDSHIP THE CALIFORNIA WORKERS
HAVE HAD TO ENDURE WHEN THE
LAPTOP PROTECTED TIME TO GRIEVE
. THE LACK OF BEREAVEMENT LEAVE
PROTECTIONS EXPOSES THE GLARING
GAP AND I LEAVE LAWS THAT END UP
COMPOUNDING THE HARDSHIPS FOR
WORKERS IN AN ALREADY DIFFICULT
TIME. EXISTING LAW PROVIDES DROP
PROTECTION FOR WORKERS TO TAKE
CARE OF A SERIOUSLY ILL FAMILY
MEMBER. BUT BOTH PROTECTION AND
THE MINUTE THE FAMILY MEMBER
PASSES AWAY. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW WORKERS TO TAKE. UP TO
FIVE DAYS OF UNPAID BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE. A MODEST AMOUNT OF TIME
TO ALLOW THEM TO GRIEVE AND
ARRANGE THE FINAL AFFAIRS. MANY
EMPLOYERS THAT ALREADY PROVIDE
FREQUENTLY BENEFITS ARE TO BE
COMMENDED FOR RECOGNIZING THE
HUMANITY OF THEIR WORKERS AND
ONE OF THE MOST DRAMATIC MOMENT
OF THEIR LIVES. ARE THAT ADDS
ADDITIONAL STRESS THE FINANCIAL
AND SECURITY. BUT WORKERS ACCESS
TO SUCH BENEFITS ARE LEFT TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THEIR EMPLOYER
WHEN TRAGEDY STRIKES. AND
WITHOUT A RIGHT GUARANTEED BY
LAW THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
BENEFIT FURTHER TRAUMATIZE THEM
OUT OF ALL NORMAL TIME. THIS
BILL IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF LOSS IN
THE STATE AS A RESULT OF A
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS WE
LOOK AHEAD TO HOW TO COPE WITH
OF NINETEEN BECOMING ENDEMIC.
AND WITH CLOSE TO NINETY
THOUSAND LIVES HAVING ALREADY
BEEN LOST IN THE STATE.
RESPECTFULLY URGE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE
SO THE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
AFFORDED THE TIME DEGREETHANK
YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE- YOU MONTROSE ON THE PHONE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. WE DO. IT
ON YOUR LINE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS WITH
LETTER HAS THIS LETTER HAS BEEN
WRITTEN TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY NINETEEN FORTY NINE THE
BURKE RECONNECT OVER REVENGE
ACT. I FOUND TRIED AT THE VIPER
I'M NOT A GRANDMOTHER A
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND THE FOUNDER
OF. MY MOTHER'S VOICE. WORKING
NO WAY TO PROVIDE THE WORK THAT
I DO IS PROVIDE MOTHER WHO HAVE
LOST CHILDREN GUN VIOLENCE I AM
FAT I'M SADDENED BY THE BY THE
FACT CONTINUE WITH CONTINUE TO
LACK UNDERSTANDING AND THE CARE. FOR THE MONSTER OF ARE NOT
ONES TO. A LOT ABOUT IT. I THINK
. BOB THIS TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
YOU. TOO MARK THIS THIS WAS THE
FIRST IN MY LIFE NOT A LOT ONE
THAT WOULD CLOSE TO THE THAT WAS
KILLED IN THE ONE JUST. ANY
PARTS IT WILL NOT. THERE WAS A
LOT OF FUN. REFLECT THE- CARE.
BUT I'M NOT COGNITIVE START THE
JOURNEY OF EXOTIC THE PROJECT.
WE ARE ALL GIVE THREE OFF OF
WORK AT TIME I DID NOT THAT IT
WOULD TAKE GOOD FOR DAY WIPING
USED TO THANK YOU BOB. FROM
CORNER. ON THE ONE THE FOCUS OF
JUST. BROKE RANKS WITH. IN SO
FAR SCOTT TO FOCUS WHAT TO YOUR
H. OR YOUR FAMILY MEMBER OF THE
DAYS THANK YOU FOR THAT YOU
DON'T FIFTY START FOR ME THE
JOURNEY THE START I WAS ENGAGED
IN CHILD A LOT BLOOD JUST.
ASSEMBLY MCAFEE NOT YOUR MY TIME
CLEESE. A. B. NINETY NINETEEN
FORTY NINE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LAPTOP. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR LOW THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS YOU'RE TAKING THOSE IF
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT YES THANK
YOU. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. FOR GOOD
MORNING CARE NUMBERS ANTHONY
DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
PROUD CO SPONSOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN FORTY NINE WE WON'T
TAKE ANY FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT
NAME AFFILIATION ANSWER FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU AGAIN IT IS ONE
ZERO. I CAN GO TO LINE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JONATHAN GO
WITH THE NATIONAL OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIANS COMMONSTORE
SUPPORTER EIGHTY NINETEEN FORTY
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
. FIND TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SIR BREMBO
CALLING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE AND
SUPPORT. LINE FIFTY YEAR OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN INFO WITH
THE FLOW- COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK GOD LINE THANK REPLYING.
FIFTY TWO. DUE TO YOUR OPEN. GOT
A LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GO HEAD TO HEAD THE
- OKAY THANK YOU I'M SORRY I
WASN'T SURE I WOULD THINK YOU
AND CANNOT EVEN UNDERSTAND THE
HOBBIT THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. KATIE WATER CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY POLITICIAN COUNCIL
PORT EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU.
EXITING ONLINE. TWENTY THREE.
BUT MORNING JACKETS ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NEXUS
LINE FORTY NINE. HI MY NAME'S
ONE ZERO THOUGHTS I'M WITH
PUBLIC COUNCIL AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY NINE THANK YOU. CONNECT
WILL GO. TO FIFTY THREE. HI I AM
JULIA PARISH WITH LEGAL AID AT
WORK A STATEWIDE NONPROFIT THAT
REPRESENTS WHAT WHICH WORKERS
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CLICK NEXT
RED LINE FIFTY FOUR. HI LYNN
EDWARD THAT HE COMMUNITY HE AND
FOR SUPPORT AS A EVEN. FOURTEEN
THANKS WE'VE GOT LINES FIVE. ONE
HALF OF THE CORRECT. DURING THE
COURTS ON BEHALF OF THE HELPFUL
ADVOCATES WORK IN TRUMP IN. AND
CURRENTLY BACK FOR INTO. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANY IN
THE TO A FOR NINETEEN FOURTEEN.
MASSING NOT OP WOULD YOU OF THE
LINES ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE B. NINETEEN
NINE. THANK YOU AND AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO. TWO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THAT ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE THE LINES. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. MR LOW YOU MAY
CLOSE. THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
AN INCREDIBLE AND THE THING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR THIS
BIPARTISAN MEASURE. THANK YOU SO
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CULTURAL PLEASE STAND BY STONE I
CUNNINGHAM I CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES. DAVIES I HOLDEN. KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES. REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE WICKS.
THE BILLS OUT ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. AND I DON'T SEE MISTER WARD. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND THE SECOND CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
DAVIES I HOLDEN. KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION I REYES. REYES HI
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE WICKS.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE BRIAN AB
EIGHTEEN TEN LEVINE AB NINETEEN
OH SIX STONE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE CARILLO AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FIVE PATTERSON AND
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX
CUNNINGHAM SO WHILE WE WAIT FOR
A LAST AUTHOR LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH. THE LIST ITEM NUMBER
ONE IS AB EIGHTEEN NINE
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES HOLDEN KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I RAISED REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE WICKS. THE
IS ON CALL IF ONE. ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS AB TWENTY THREE THIRTEEN
I'LL TAKE A MOTION. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE CULTURAL PLEASE STONE
AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM DAVIES DAVIES I
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I
REYES REYES HI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I WICKS. THAT PHYLLIS OUT ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB. SEVENTEEN
FOURTEEN COOPER OF THE COMMOTION
. THANK YOU DO HAVE A MO AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATE CHOLERA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES DAVIES I
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I
REYES. RESIGNED FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I WICKS. THAT BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE DALY I'LL TAKE
A MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. DAVIES. DAVIES I HOLDEN KALRA
FIVE KALRA KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. FREEZE I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE WICKS. THAT OUT
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY THREE GABRIEL ALL TAKE A
MOTION. THANK YOU THAT MOTION IS
PASS CALL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
DAVIES DAVIES I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE WICKS. THE
DALLAS OUT AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN IS AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
TWO KALRA I'LL TAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS COLOR OAKLEY'S. STONE
HI STONE I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. DAVIES. DAVIES I HOLDEN
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. REYES AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I WICKS. OKAY THE BILL
IS OUT I'M GONNA GO BACK UP TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX WHERE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND ABILITY ON
CALL THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT GIPSON I'M OF THE
CALL. KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I WICKS. THAT
BILL IS OUT. ADAM NUMBER SEVEN
AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO IS OUT BUT
YOU CAN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE WICKS. HEY THAT
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE JONES SAWYER IS ON
CALL I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
HOLDEN KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I. THE BILL IS OUT I
THINK EVERYONE HERE HAS BEEN ON
. NINE WERE STILL WAITING FOR
MISTER WARD FOR ITEM TEN.
EVERYBODY SPENT ON A LOT OF IT.
SO I THINK WE'RE UP TO DATE FOR
THE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE. SURE.
THE NATIONAL COMPUTER- I
UNDERSTAND YOU ON HIS WAY OVER
SO THANK FOR THE OFFERED BUT
WE'LL GET A CHANCE. TO GET HERE. HAS MAKES.
THE CARD IN THE- EASTERN
DISTRICT. RIGHT THIS. YOUR HONOR
YEAH.
MR WELCOME TO WILL NOW MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND SKEWS ME AND A
SECOND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE A BEING BETWEEN TWO
BUILDINGS YOU'LL NOW AND NO NO
WE'RE USING IN THE LAST THE
ALPHABET ALL THE BRIEF- AB TWO
FIVE FIVE NINE THAT'S THE
STANDARD FOR REASONABLE SCREEN
REPORTS TO BE USED DURING THE
RENTAL APPLICATION PROCESS. BY
USING A REUSABLE SCREENING
REPORT WRITERS ONLY HAVE TO PAY
A ONE TIME FOR THE REPORT THAT
CAN BE USED MANY TIMES OVER
THIRTY DAYS THEREBY SAVING THE
RENTER HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS AND
WILL ALLOW LANDLORDS TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY REVIEW VERIFIED
APPLICANT INFORMATION I WANT TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR
REACHING OUT TO ME AND I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM.
IN THE ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I SEE NO
ONE ELSE IS IN THE ROOM BUT I
THINK YOU DO HAVE A WITNESS ON
THE TELEPHONE. BROOK HUGHLEY. SO
IS BROKE. HE'LL BE WITH US ON
THE PHONE. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE A
WITNESS FOR AB. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY NINE. BOB LET ME SEE IF
I'VE GOT A PROCARE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE HOW YOU KNOW HER LINE
DROPPED IT APPEARS. I'M SORRY
SAY THAT AGAIN. SHE WAS NOT IT
LOOKS LIKE HER LINE HAS HAS
DISCONNECTED. OKAY IF. YOU CAN
CALL BACK IN. TO GO AHEAD AND
CALL BACK AND WE'LL MOVE FORWARD
IN OUR PROCESS BUT WHEN SHE DOES
CALL BACK IN WILL ALLOW HER TO
TESTIFY. OR IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY NINE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR OF THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
NINE. THANK YOU AND IF SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME.
AND NOBODY IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY NINE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE OPERATOR OPEN
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY NINE. Q.
AND IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT HERE.
WE GOT A LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLEAN GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THAT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE OF
THE DOCTOR AND THE COMEDIAN
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH US
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO REACH AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
AUTHOR- PRAYER THE BILL BEING
HEARD IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ANNEXING ALIGN FORTY ONE IT.
COULD GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME AT
THE END OF MADISON I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE OFTEN AMENDED
TO BELIEVE YOU CAN FIND A
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THEN FURTHER AT THIS TIME
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU RIGHT ARE
PRETTY MAKE CLOSE ALLIANCE OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR THREATS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS BILL
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU THAT WHEN
I'VE MET WITH OUR FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE AGED OUT. THIS WAS ONE
OF THEIR BIGGEST COMPLAINTS THAT
THEY HAD SO LITTLE MONEY AND
YET. EVERYBODY WAS ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FEE TO DO A CREDIT
CHECK. IT SEEMS LIKE A
COMMONSENSE APPROACH BUT IT
ISN'T SO I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE TOUR INTRODUCING THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE- OR COMMENTS I THANK U.
S. AWARD FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW IT SOUNDS VERY
COME BY- WITH. THE OPPOSITION
OUT THERE BUT- I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THEM APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING WORKED WITH THIS
COMMITTEE- A. N. I AGREE THIS IS
A ACTUALLY A PRETTY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND SOMETHING THAT. NEEDS
TO BE RESOLVED. SO PROTECT THEM.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS RIGHT
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVERS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO PRIVACY CALDERON PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
DAVIES. HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES REYES AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I WICKS FIVE
WEEKS AYE. THAT BILLS OUT THANK
YOU MISTER WARD OKAY SO LET'S GO
. YES THIS YEAR IF YOU WANT YEAH
LET'S GO BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
AGENDA. AND ROLL THROUGH FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS SO THE CONSENT
AGENDA. HOLDEN WICKS HI WIXII. I
AM NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN OH
NINE AGUIAR-CURRY IS ON CALL AND
WIN LIFT CALL HOLDEN WICKS. XII
RIGHT THAT IS NOW OUT THANK YOU.
ITEM NEVER TO AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN BELOW HOLDEN WICKS
WIXII. THE ITEM NUMBER. THREE
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN HOLDEN WICKS
WIXII THANK YOU AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE DALY HOLDEN WICKES
WIXII. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE GABRIEL
HOLDEN WICKES WICKES I REMEMBER
SIX AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
GIPSON WICKS. EXIDE I DID NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE OH TWO JONES
SAWYER WICKS LOOKS I HAVE NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE
JONES SAWYER HOLDEN. K. BUT A
NUMBER NINE AB NINETEEN FOURTEEN
I LOW HOLDEN WICKS WEBSITE. ADAM
NUMBER TEN WE'VE DONE AND ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN. OKAY WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR MR HOLDEN WHO WENT
OFF. ELEVEN OKAY SO I'M NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO
KALRA HOLDEN WICKS. SUCCESS
RIGHT THANK YOU MS WORKS FOR
JOINING US TODAY WHEN A WHOLE
THE WORLD OPEN FOR MR HOLDEN HE
HAD TO GO PRESENT ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO I KNOW HE IS ON HIS
WAY WE WILL WAIT A BIT FOR.
THANK YOU. BY FRIENDS.
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH. NO
WORRIES CHRIS OKAY SO LET'S JUST
RUN THROUGH. ALL THE ITEMS.
SINCE YOU'RE HERE FOR MOST OF
THE DAY BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE A
QUORUM. RIGHT SO CONSENT AGENDA.
HOLDEN TOLD I'D THANK YOU. ITEM
ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN OH NINE AG WE
ARE CURRY HOLDEN. OVERNIGHT I
DON'T NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN BLOOM HOLDEN WILL DENY
. NUMBER THREE AB SEVENTEEN
FOURTEEN COOPER HOLDEN WELL THE
NINE. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR AB
TWENTY THREE ANYONE DALY HOLDEN
. THE NIGHT. I THANK YOU WE HAVE
YOU ON FIVE. YEAH SIX OKAY I
SAID ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY THREE GABRIEL HOLDEN
FOR THE NINE. I THINK WE HAVE
YOU ON SIX AND A SEVEN OKAY I AM
NOT EIGHT AB FIVE NINETY FIVE
JONES SAWYER. WELL THE NIGHT.
ADAM NUMBER NINE A. B. NINETEEN
FORTY NINE LOW HOLDEN. I AM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
NINE WARD HOLDEN. HOLDEN I TELL
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY TWO KALRA HOLDEN. VERY
GOOD OKAY WE ARE COMPLETE WITH
OUR BUSINESS TODAY THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH AND WE ARE ADJOURNED.
BUT THE.